[Music]
foreign
get it
Monday
April
11th [__] yo another week to
taxes
[Laughter]
kick that lead this is so [__] good
you really gotta hand it to this [__]
guy
the he had a rock bands way before that
was cool
he had a rock body count body count they
were on Lollapalooza and cop killer it
was very controversial Clinton a typical
yeah the whole [__] and this guy is
now on a TV show going on 10 seasons he
always plays a cop too always because
the New Jack City he went against type
and it's stuck
how great is that you really Gotta Give
it to this guy this is It's almost like
if you concentrate on something you hate
you might kind of become that thing he
hated cops and now he's constantly
in the mind of a cop portraying a cop
he used to portray the gangster and now
he betrays the cop it's weird it's very
weird yeah
he's great 25 [__] years he's great
on that show too it's not like it's not
like sometimes when there's a celebrity
on the show it's like okay they're just
here to get their Twitter followers he's
he he's always been good on that yeah
dog he was the one shot one on it he was
great yeah
really good to me what do we have here
Joey
but the other guy was a dick Richard
Belzer
on the set he was a dick Belzer played
that what's the name of that character
scumbag yeah whatever it is he played
that character on like six different
shows he ran it down on Stern one time
like that character not the name and
everything is on like a bunch of
different shows
which is weird like because it was on
homicide and then he was on these
otherwise and they're like and they're
like uh you you you're the same
character you're the same guy same name
wear all black
all that [__] he's the same guy have you
ever seen his comedy because I haven't
really real like he can't yeah you know
he was part of like the
the uh the 80s I think the 70s 70s like
the late 70s early 80s I had a
revolution of uh right the Boom is what
they call it yeah but he did something
else too
I just came he did heroin did he yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah oh my God for how long I
don't know but that was his thing
he's an ex-heroin addict what's going on
[__] chilling just got back to
town on Thursday so when did you leave
exactly I left uh on the 4th of January
and what made you just get up and go to
New York well our shaffir
uh he put a thing on Facebook it was
like I'll switch apartments with anybody
you pay your La rent
I'll pay my New York rent
and you know that's what he said and uh
I was like he's on Facebook I
immediately texted him
like I'm like yo all right
this to me you know I I didn't see any
reason why I shouldn't go and I wanted
to go so I went
you know it's pretty spontaneous
decision yeah no no that's always the
best one yeah and was it did you have a
great day it was it was the [__] man
three months in New York City yeah yeah
I got real [__] used to it bumping on
trains yeah yeah a slice of pizza here
slice Brews ladies sets a hot dog and
sets it was the [__] yeah it was the
[__] I loved it I loved it and I did
some I did a little bit of road work and
I could take the train to it you know I
didn't have to get on an airplane I went
to Syracuse I went to
um
Albany uh both funny bones yeah yeah
they were fun I like the Albany better
in Syracuse but they were still good
they're still Syracuse is still good
how's the Syracuse one Syracuse one's
pretty good I like Albany better I mean
it's still [__] great why why'd you
like about Albany better Albany they
laugh more of my [__] okay
very simple I'm Albany looking these
days uh you know you know how these
funny bones are you're always in The
Burbs
so it looked fine but I was in Albany
last summer and it's cool you know lots
of downtowns are coming together with
like they always put bars and
restaurants and stuff in Old factories
and stuff so albany's going through the
same thing it's it's pretty cool
downtown nightlife I have I was there in
June for one night and it was [__]
awesome they used to do comedy at the
bus station in Albany really somebody
used to book a room 20 years ago
on a Thursday night at the train at the
bus station so what you did was you took
the bus from Manhattan yeah to Albany
right all the train where the [__] right
the train yeah
and you took a cab to the thing and then
you went to the hotel spent the night
yeah and got back to the hotel with
street blocks in the train station maybe
four blocks of [__] real dive that's
awesome when you got back on the train
the next morning and you went it was
part of Rascals not Rascals bananas okay
they have bananas up in [__] hell
don't they in Nyack New York something
not well not I know go bananas I don't
know a banana okay the gold bananas is
in Cincinnati yeah yeah I think bananas
is in Fort Lee New it's in New Jersey
okay under the bridge it's right there
that's what the one bananas and then
they have another bananas
Poughkeepsie and Poughkeepsie
[Laughter]
you look that up let me tell you
something you son of a guy that's a
brutal three days yeah I'm sure you're
in front of a [__] gas station yeah
hotel and you know guys like you and me
we just go up there we figured we'd go
up there take the bus up right get in
our room by four yeah the [__] hotel
food was horrendous dude and it was the
hotel like I said and the gas station oh
yeah was chips dog yeah I did I did a
gig the last gig I really really truly
hated was in Atlantic City New Jersey uh
the comedy stop Bobcat part
went there when you when I got there
what was this this was in May last year
I go there and they hand you a piece of
paper that says thanks for your patience
with late payments as in you're not
getting paid this week what you're
getting paid whenever
seven day week uh work week the crowds
are [__] horrific
uh you staying in the Ritz which is
Nucky Thompson's old joint it's gone to
[__] [__] it's horrible I leave
this [__] club goes out of business
I never get paid for the shittiest
[__] week I've done in a long time
I'm surprised
he's a crook and you know what he's been
in business
this is Jesus left Chicago he said yeah
he had a room 70s or 80s yeah I've done
that one yeah it's the Laugh Factory now
yeah so is everything closed in Atlantic
City I mean is it just kaputs you got to
be able to speak Spanish to order
Italian food out there dude
again no I don't think everything's
closed everything's still going on a
couple they still got Hooters shit's
still going on the borgatas still living
large I went to Atlantic City twice as a
consumer yeah and it was okay to me one
time me and my friend just went for crab
legs and well eating crab legs I got a
late gig in Connecticut like Roger Paul
calls me like a nine o'clock gig in
Connecticut yeah
and then I went there one time as a
comic and I knew that one time and I
went PA called Dan because it was a joke
it was a Friday night UFC and me and Joe
went with like six of us I think Ari was
there and I left him I did the one nine
left and I went North I didn't want to
stay I'm in Jersey what am I going to
stay with you [__] Knuckleheads let
me go up to my family and see the family
you know what too someone offered me
work that week like like last minute
uh yeah yeah when he comes like you want
to work for me in Vegas like I can't do
that to them I can't bail on them last
minute and then they didn't [__] pay
me
do you see where your morals get you Lee
always look out for number one it's
crazy you have to and then I was talking
to someone today and she was saying that
she did a job like at the beginning of
the year and her agent like it's it's
kind of crazy how like the checks go to
the agents first instead of the people
who do the jobs
what kind of job it is okay if it's
stand up it should not go to your agent
nope unless you're a millionaire and
it's a sixty thousand dollar wire
transfer to your engine and he takes the
commission out and he gives it to you
that's that's Kevin Hart that's crazy I
have to wait for it though right now
let's say you do a commercial
or TV show or movie
if you do a a commercial you got 30 days
to get paid
now to some people 30 days is like okay
but when you're [__] living here and
you're broke and you're doing 15 sets
you count the 30 days I literally do you
you know when the mailman's coming I
knew when the mailman I used to wait for
the mailman I used to take action for
the mailman I had a Filipino mailman in
Hollywood I got to meet him and gnome I
knew him [__] well yeah what sort of
action were you taking basketball he was
always anything he bet every night he
bet every night I hooked him up with a
bookie he was my friend I would see him
and he'd go I have check for you
and I'd wait by the house until he came
my life was that mailbox so for people
who really don't understand right 30
days is a long time long time now you
have film and TV it's 10 days
if you pay sag
it's 10 days but let me tell you what
happens they do something in 10 days
your agent deposits it in their bank
account
and then it takes two weeks they slow
for you yep and she said it was called
processing now let me explain something
to you
you've never ever ever seen Joey Diaz
hot then when you take my checks in
those days and I was expecting cocaine
yeah and that check went to my [__]
wrong agent or something
I was with Daniel Hoff this last time
for maybe three years and I liked them I
got along with them but when I first got
with them in 2000 there was something
going on with a check one time I like I
had been with them booked a couple jobs
and everything was hunky dory but there
was one particular time I bumped into
something like hey man Daniel hop has
taken a long time with the check that's
all I needed to hear I did this job and
I [__] who's who's uh
Ben Affleck's wife Jennifer Garner it
was her show on ABC remember when she
shows Alias yeah that's no
no I'm sorry it wasn't her show I'm
sorry it was the other girl that had the
kind of cop Show and her father was
whatever I did that show I taped it
right here I don't like the shrimp that
disgusting strip club on the other side
of Victory up there
I did it up there and waited for that
check [__] three weeks I was Furious
called the production company they said
listen when did you shoot the job I
signed the 29th they said we sent it on
the second
it was like the 18th of the month I was
[__] hot I kept calling the agent we
didn't get it we didn't get it we didn't
get it we didn't get it we didn't get it
with that [__] mailman come on
Horseback and I was on coke then guys I
didn't [__] around right I finally
called them one more I just woke up and
I said listen that check better appeared
today bro
it has to have been today yeah and I
called them back at five and they said
the check isn't out here
I said I'm gonna go down there right now
talk to [__] Danny and when I got
there my paperwork was on the wall with
my check and they had gotten rid of me
as a client really yeah because I broke
I knew them I knew they were stealing
yeah are they still in business they're
still in business and I talked to him I
bumped into him at the vet and like a
gentleman I went up to and I apologized
and he goes I remember that and he told
me the whole story he had a partner yeah
and he goes if you come to my office
I'll show you the settlement and the
whole thing the guy robbed them put 208
000 right and they recovered 100 and the
guy went to jail now when he comes out
he goes well I paid all those checks he
goes I'm still in business because if I
was a Rob that I wouldn't have been in
business he got convicted at the time
and there were a few agents that were
taking clients really Nick tutorial's
agent took him for Jesus you know
there's a lot of there's agents now that
accommodate this is an agent that was
running a scam here
that was booking you and telling the
club to send him a Jack and then listen
when it comes to film and television I
understand what about the it's a process
the casting agent who like last week
just got fired from their show because
they were running a casting workshop and
then charging people to audition for the
show
well you got to remember one thing that
this spawn what you have here is the
land of suckers okay when everybody gets
here the first three weeks you're a
sucker unless you have a friend that
breaks it down for you people will extra
yeah thinking that they're gonna get a
sag voucher you know that's not gonna
happen people become extras like I had a
guy that goes listen man I'll make you
an accident one week you'll be in the
movie talking
this is this guy's scam I know that
never happens right but he's like just
let the director meet you one week
you'll be on the set doing lines with
[__] Leonardo DiCaprio of course when
I got here Titanic was shooting and four
different uh extra agencies had this
account it was a huge shoot right you
know that boat went down they had
thousands of people and you see Joey he
was in the band playing violence they
had people down there going to they
would tell you listen if you want work
119 a day in gas alone to go to instant
leaders and back
like they would give you a buck 20 just
for gas to take the day trip you could
be in the Titanic
not a bad game so they had a scam going
if you went down there and got chosen
they paid you to 120 for gas and then
they paid you the 300 for the day
but if you didn't get chosen then you
didn't get to guess something crazy
something just [__] crazy
but a lot of people were going down it
but there was actually people that were
selling extra work going we'll get you
in the Titanic next week become an extra
go on set and within one week you'll be
doing lines on the Orlando capria there
was there was a thing called cast net
when I first got here yeah when you
signed an agent you had a sign with it
we will not book you unless you're a
castlet you know how many cast Nets I've
been here over the years
it's the same stupid scam something that
you give them then they'll make casting
easier you know put your head shot on
this site and casting people go looking
no they don't yeah job postings no they
don't yeah premium for nothing yeah no
they don't no they don't no they don't
know they've done all that [__] was
[__] I'm so happy I didn't get
involved in any of that [__] at all I
didn't believe and extra work I didn't
believe in none of that like cast Nets
you know uh you need to do this anything
that costs money
because what we have is a bunch of kids
that come out of college and they grow
up watching cyanide live
and they move here and they get Daddy's
credit card and they join improv
Olympics
you follow me they get a brand new car
and they because the dad goes here's the
deal you got two years now I need to run
your game yeah and if in two years you
don't make it then you come work for me
at the [__] box company right in my
20 years here I've known five kids that
one day called me and said hey man I'm
leaving
where you going I'm going Rico was the
last one giving me Rico the
youngestino's friend maybe I went back
to Boston the only construction company
is that on the construction company
right so the whole time he was he was
getting shot we wonder what the [__] did
the kid do how's this kid party every
[__] that yeah his dad was cutting up
a check
and he was doing little gigs around town
for 50 bucks and but that's 60 percent
of Hollywood like when you go deep into
Hollywood in the inner right it's it's
new Advantage all those acting schools
when you're around like I was [__]
40. I was 35 going acting class yeah and
I would listen I would uh have uh scene
partners and you have to go to their
homes
and I diely
what would they say to you
it was just here I was struggling you
know doing spots at the store yeah
dying I'd go to acting class on Tuesdays
and he put me with somebody you know and
this these guys lived like
the one girl lived on Wilshire
it cost me eight dollars just to park in
her [__] parking garage
and it was like she was like somebody's
girlfriend like on the side
but that's what she wanted to do she
wanted to act so he took off her tattoos
he fixed it she was a black chick from
Florida the SE gorgeous but she was
country
she's conscious she had never eaten with
silverware and he was just giving her a
makeover like some guy met her and just
bought her an apartment
I mean you could see by if you looked at
this woman I'm sorry to say that you
could see that she was a racehorse like
she was black and she got she was
[__] beautiful she got tattoos hit
removed like she was showing me yeah he
removed all my tattoos she didn't tell
me who it was I had a feeling who it was
she's a black chick he's a white dude I
know who it is I have no idea hey she
invited me over do I have to do the same
moving for coffee a couple times she was
my friend I forget what her name is now
this has to be 15 [__] years I don't
feel bad Bobby forgot to and her
neighbor was Shaq
really like her neighbor was shy like he
lived right down the [__] on the
other side it was like every floor had
two tenants
one of those reports and the other
tenant was she actually kill the tenant
was shot in the penthouse he lived below
and you could see his head above the
porch so he cleaned up her tattoos he he
fixed the feet
she was beautiful she was wrong with her
feet like she just had like she was she
never had shoes like you know one of
those black people I'm not I'm not even
trying to be funny I mean when I tell
you this that this was
when she was telling me these stories I
was just sitting there they shot a
couple movies down there and he met him
huh he knew it for like a year he kept
in touch with him when she turned like
19 he goes come on I got a life for you
come on move to LA I set you up in an
apartment car she had like a like an
Audi that was all done I always wonder
when I see those kind of girls in like
those cars like and I guess that's kind
of sexist but then again it's like it's
like young like 18 year old girls
driving like Range Rovers out here
there was another guy
it's either Elise or denarium
that I met I went to his house
and he lived
in the heart of Beverly Hills
like this kid drove to whatever that's
why you never know who the [__] it is at
all this time yeah
we did a couple of scenes they started
telling me who he was like
his dad is a big composer with some [__]
and his dad is always like in Europe
like you haven't seen he sees his dad
once a year but they automatically send
him like thirty two thousand dollars God
damn that's a lot of money could you
imagine just getting that amount of
money every month I don't know what I
would do I don't know it was I met I met
another kid that is a father was a
professional
quarterback
and this kid
again just for lack of confidentiality
guys the father was a star in the NFL I
mean Major League star
and the kid he probably never talked to
this kid do you know what I'm saying
like you could tell that this kid had a
hole in them
he was trying to act he was trying to
stand up I mean he had him in dancing
classes he had him with a trainer I mean
I'm not kidding you yeah like I used to
meet him and he would show up and tell
me about his day he had a nutritionist
but the kid was just damaged good
because his dad never put the effort
into the whole ocean and never
like it was I mean he was a sweet kid he
meant well you know it was always uh he
would call him and go Joey [__] that
sandwich place
let me take it and Mr Chow we'll do the
scene at Mr Chow and other people in the
back like he could pay off anybody I
guess and I felt bad I would go no no
let's do the scene over there you know
yeah
I don't know what then I bumped into him
I bumped into him like maybe five years
ago he still hadn't booked anything
still in acting class
still with a trainer
he got a speech guy because he was from
the south right so he had a speech guy
that came in two hours a day guys
and worked with him on getting his
accent taken away because he was
so you know Southern you know so I early
on I bumped into these young kids it was
a different exposure and when I didn't
invite him to The Comedy Store
would blow up why is that because
they had never seen that type of
like I even met people from improv
Olympic I met this really cool girl and
her boyfriend
I met the girl first and then she
introduced me to the boyfriend and they
were an improv Olympic and they came to
watch a comedy store on a Friday night
like I had like a great set in front of
him and then they couldn't shut up about
it like they had never seen anything
like that they were around so many weak
people right right so many levels like
they were yeah and comedians too like
even when they're struggling they're
still actually doing comedy they're
doing what they do whereas acting you
kind of gotta wait around conditions
yeah and I really you know I I wanted to
attack acting from two heads when I
moved here I wanted to I always thought
this listen at the time I was a schlub
at the store so I would go to the store
yeah I'd get spots but my spots were at
midnight yeah so guys like me you and I
at the time would go at 10 and we'd talk
and [__] and what do you talk about
Lee shows up and tells me about the club
in Memphis
that everybody buys merch right you know
everybody talks to you about that it's a
one-sided conversation so the reason why
I went to acting class wasn't as much as
not to Act was to see the lives of
actors to see if it was really what they
[__] said it was
you know but I went to the wrong place I
went to Havana chubbock which is already
like 200 a month yeah these are all
[__] kids is that expensive
I know I know it's a lot of money but is
it a lot of money for acting classes
acting classes now in Hollywood got to
be 275 300. yeah easy I went to Leslie
Khan and I saw what you're talking about
oh God this one's a Playboy Playmate
this one's a [__] quarterback for the
Buffalo Bills and then you know just
like you said a bunch of pretty kids
that uh that it kind of had some money
and didn't really know what to do with
their lives and actually to some
talented people but you know so what I
learned a lot in acting class that I can
apply to stand up and stuff absolutely
I'm not saying that it was good how long
will you get Leslie Khan for uh on and
off really only a couple months at a
time used to charge a hundred dollars
for a private for half for coaching
private coaching for a half hour
which is expensive but also good if you
don't know what you're going to do on an
audition and they go just do this this
yeah but then you know what to do no
it's too much listen what scale 660.
okay listen to me guys at home let's go
down break it down probably 660 after
taxes you probably get overtime let's
say you bring home 500 bucks okay so
660. yeah that's low on taxes yeah 660
in La if you're single whatever let's
say 500 so we're out to about 660 you're
sending out 10 is 60. Right 20 is 120
and you're punching out 100 for the
[__] thing
so you're punching out 220 from 500
you're getting what two [__] 80. the
actual major television show you're
gonna clear 280 if that and everybody
out there listening to pay attention to
like the what you're starting with
what the [__] are you talking about did
I make that in a week right but that's
what goes that's what you get if you're
lucky out here if you're lucky after
that job but here's the other side of
that like a guy like me I'd pay the
yardstick because I'd want to do the
best performance I could of course take
some of her advice I always I was always
not like there's people that I know
stand-up comics
if they get to a certain level and I'm
first of all I'm not going for auditions
and second of all
I'm not uh reading for them that this
wasn't written for me I think that's
just a shitty idea I like going in and
getting a [__] job I wanted to learn
how to go in and get a job so when I
signed up for acting class for a few
months I actually hung out with those
[__] Knuckleheads from no schools
yeah and I was very totally upset
because it was like the little like
swingers
currently going oh my God guess what
we're doing the scene from
Titanic and you look at them what the
[__] are you talking about a scene I
want to get into the [__] movies
once I did two scenes I was done yeah I
was done like I don't know what you're
talking about right and I remember
Tuesdays was my I would go into acting
class Tuesdays at 10. and every you know
it started like when I first started I
would go there every week religiously
for like 90 days then I started popping
auditions on Tuesdays and I started
working and it was
that was the first time I ever felt uh
like I was doing something because I
gotta be honest with you guys out of the
15 people in the class
nobody was working right and they'd suck
these kids in I'd watch it I'd sit there
and see these kids going no no
I'm not ready to go for auditions here
what are you talking about yeah go out
there get in the mix the only way you're
going to learn how to audition is by
auditioning and eating ass yeah is by
doing you'll learn real quick listen
once you feel that pain yeah once you
feel that pain you'll learn but these
kids were petrified
they stayed out here they bucked around
they did a play one of those shitty
planes oh yeah and they pack up their
bags and lay away and the same thing
happens for stand up because like they
get in the lower Circle Echelon group
where it's this fake camaraderie like
I'm gonna go to your shows and I bring
my friend and we'd come to your show and
support and then we're like no no no no
support
these people aren't really stand ups and
they call like I made stand-ups all the
time and I've never seen them before you
too well yeah but I remember when you
used to host the um The Comedy Store and
you'd be you would explain to the
audience that some of these Comics
coming up are [__] Hollywood comics
and they think they got a cute haircut
so they'll be good at stand up
and so I remember you explaining that to
the audience so you were thinking about
this a long time ago oh a long time yeah
yeah because I saw the differences I saw
the people that you could start telling
the people they're gonna stick around
for a few weeks
and you could tell the people that dove
into this and I've been wrong oh don't
get me wrong sure sure I've been wrong
about guys that are giving me hip
beatings and I look for them you know
I'm out and also Matt Fulton approaches
me and says my name is Matt Voltron
you know I saw you at Rogan I really
enjoyed I started doing comedy and I do
this and this and this I started looking
for manifolds right just to see if
you're blowing a smoke up my ass sure
I'm a comment and you also see guys that
like don't have it and then you turn
around maybe three or four years later
and they're just killing it killing it
because they've they that's the thing
about stand-up that you're saying you
actually have to face the reality it's
not like oh if I get an audition I'll do
this
pretty much couple times a week you're
going up and facing it you get good
really quick or you quit because you
can't deal with the pain unless you're
one of these people that's just
delusional and and doesn't really know
how well they're doing
well there's a lot of those there's a
lot of those I came up and done with a
lot of those I just re-hosted the Open
Mic at The Comedy Store last Monday oh
cool and I realized that
years ago if the list had 20 people Liam
I'm not talking eight of them were
homeless people yeah I was
you know crazy people and then the store
the the scene was kind of Comedy was
kind of dead back then and so like there
was this weird uh homeless person like
delusional like I'm gonna make it at the
store thing and a lot of people were
homeless we're really homeless or
definitely a lot of people were crazy
I don't want to say homeless I couchsurf
that's for sure yeah you coucher do a
different kind of homeless I think I
lived in my car
yeah but you weren't like the the crazy
no I wasn't combing my hair in a [__]
pigeon puddle you know but I was still
homeless and that's and I know I know
what it was like and I knew what it was
like laying in that car thinking I gotta
put pieces together to get into an
apartment and
is what I have to do and get a security
deposit yeah that happened to me after
I've been out here for like 10 years and
I've even been on TV and stuff
like
I was like it wasn't like I wasn't
working and I was completely broke but I
didn't have enough for like a security
deposit and
rent and so I was just kind of bouncing
around
uh staying on people's couches and stuff
around for a year out of here man no
shame because I think the people that
let me bounce around on their couches
whatever knew how hard I was working
that's not what I did dinner Lee was
busy I called him he was doing something
I would Felicia my wife
another friend of mine
because it was funny on the way home my
wife goes I have nothing against your
friend
but this is like the third time you're
invited around to dinner with us
and I was like wow
let me put you this way
she worked 15 hours over 50 hours a week
and she makes a dick
and in 1994 when I lived in Boulder you
know I never forgot this this is this is
comedy 101 guys okay you could write
jokes you know what makes a comment good
the story I'm going to tell you you can
write jokes and you can perform every
[__] night
but what makes you really good on stage
is part of this [__] journey and
getting to appreciate the big picture
and I'm looking you in the face like man
lately I had nothing
I was making ten thousand a month and
snorting every dime or giving it to a
[__] attorney for child support or
child support at the time I was in my
own person how are you making ten
thousand a month at the sports betting
service okay
we're at the sports betting service I
met this kid doesn't matter what his
[__] name was a kid from Connecticut
he was uh
if I was 32 30 he was about 32. his wife
was maybe 50.
the ugliest woman on the planet but her
parents owned
a huge line of restaurants and they up
and down the east coast and she was
there and she got a paycheck every month
that would make both of us gag three of
us gag what they sent her in the mail
and he leached on to her but he wasn't a
bad kid this kid was not a bad kid he
just he had a high Taste of money and
this was going to keep him and he liked
Porsches those old Porsches and she had
one and he had one they had matching
ones and they had the t-shirts and you
know it was just crazy but the point of
the story is I gotta tell you something
guys just so the people at home know the
truth
I get home at night and I had the rocky
apartment that I lived downstairs I had
the kitchen I never turned the stove on
did you have cuff and Link no I have two
turtles no I didn't even have a couple
left I had a TV a bench a weightlifting
bench with Olympic weight and I use that
as a dinner table and a riding station
and then I had a couch and I had a bed
that just fit in a room nothing else fit
in the room like the bed was so big it
was so much bigger than the room that it
just laid like that you know
and I never cooked that was ordered out
or ate shitty food right the life and
these guys would call me I had a pager
and they would call me and I would
finagle into the uh the people that
owned the houses the downstairs had a
phone line I call him back like what's
up and you go where I am home Brown
[__] you hungry
he knew I was hungry right yeah I go
yeah why what's up when you go me enough
Mama gonna come over and get you
you know what I was doing stand-up man I
was doing I was really working I was
really working at them getting nowhere
well I took them to a radio show with me
one night somebody invited me to do and
I took them they had they had a car and
they drove me I need around 11 o'clock
man they go we'll drive you and they sat
there and they were like so happy for me
so they knew how hard this meant to me
and they'd call me take me to the house
feed me and then they'd both go to bed
and [__] and go Joey we have 200 movies
here stay here and watch movies we got
weed
you got the balcony I didn't stay there
until three in the morning in these
people's homes eat that food smoke that
weed watch their movies you know many
times they brought it up to my face
never she ended up dying and I sent
flowers and he's still around bald and
he called me once a year
to say something weird to me or whatever
but I thought for six months they offend
me three blocks from them were the
couches my buddies and and uh
Mississippi that
I mean it used to have to pick up my
daughter and bring it to my wife
because the court order said like
I would go to the house at night and
smoke weed and they'd say do you want a
chicken you know I didn't have money for
food but the point of the story being
that
this is what happens when you try yeah
when the universe knows you're trying it
takes care of you I'm telling you right
now if you really want something
and you really work hard on it there's
going to be months that you're light on
the [__] rent Man true and Matt you
were out you out car payment [__] you
know student loans this [__] adds up I
understand never mind addiction and
[__] weed and booze you know yeah and
clothes and transportation and car
insurance and there's some months that
you get ahead and there's some months
that man that somebody called you on the
30th to make sure a [__] month yeah
and that's when you become religious you
go yeah yeah it's got to be a God no
it's called the universe yeah you know
when I was sitting there at that
Atlantic City gig
hating life
thinking what am I going to do in June I
thought I was getting paid too that's
when I thought I was getting paid had
nothing on the books for June got a
little text message from old Danny
Daniel Tosh I was like you you know you
want to go on tour with me next month
[__]
yeah you know that was in a month I
thought I might be going out of business
I used to always think I was going out
of business too like I'm three weeks
away from going out of business right
and also when somebody calls you with a
gig in Arizona yeah the best gig but
you're in business not the best gig but
you're in business though you just
bought another week of your business
Kaboom but then I don't understand why
people leave like I get unless you're
the movement of a family they were never
in it in the first place but not even
that but like let's say if you go out of
business if you're gonna move back home
and live a family there has to be
someone out here you could live with in
theory I don't think people are willing
to get down and dirty and really [__]
go through it I I don't think most
people are especially if you don't
really know what you're doing in the
first place see Joe you knew you wanted
to do stand up you're already doing
Standalone well I tell you what happened
with me yeah let's be honest yeah
this is all I had medical treatment yeah
this is all I had at the time
it was 32 I had families
no matter what degree I had
could I get a [__] job right you know
I was going to be one of those guys with
a tattoo working at Subway
you know you were going to 11 o'clock on
that 50 year old sure that has like a
Pink Floyd shirt on he was that cool I
call it the Ghost of Christmas music but
now life life just moved a little too
[__] fast right right and here you
are at Subway sandwich with some 22 year
old Tanya gold [__] mop yeah because
you wanted to party and go see [__]
REO Speedwagon yeah and stay fair with
you know and [__] that boss I'm going to
see Aryan okay you just lost a job
making 22 an hour but at least you got
that cool tattoo yeah but you went to
see REO speed you smell my feet no these
are the Adidas no I smell roses but sure
so I didn't realize your shoes were on
that was it I had no options I know I'm
just like when I turned to stand up
comedy I said I've done everything
I've been a cook
I've been a bartend I'm in security I've
sold Coke weed
shoes neon what didn't I sell insurance
on the phone what haven't I sold if I go
for this
I gotta go for this number one I got a
five-year-old daughter
that if I go for this I want to go for
this to make her proud and that was the
original plan like let me go do this
and I'll come back in a couple years and
I'll [__] put this whole thing
together it didn't work out that way
that was the sacrifice there's always
going to be a sacrificial [__] lamp
there's a girlfriend who's left behind
some of these feelings are hurt that
you're making the move you're making
there's always something who's going to
be a little upset with you for you
making the move you're making right or
the decision you're making because we
can't please everybody there's always we
always have a friend who's a schlep who
was too scared he's never going to get
it together anyway he's doing comedy too
but he stayed he [__] stayed and did
whatever and he had the excuses
it breaks my heart when I have a
conversation with Matt full try at The
Comedy Store
and I encourage him and he encourages me
and we talk and then one day a guy like
that disappears
and granted you may be doing comedy and
whatever hellhole you move back to but
something just wasn't right right you
know what I'm saying like yeah and I've
seen a lot of guys and listen what's the
number one killer in the marriage
I don't know money problems yeah that's
what I was gonna say
after a while
unless you're [__] [__] you get
sick of this right you get sick of this
lifestyle only a [__] like myself
I'm calling myself a [__] idiot I've
been sick of it listen man I gotta into
this in 91. I got into this in June of
91. all right between us at the time I
had it all I had money in the bank I had
a truck I had a car I owned a condo
everything was beautiful
by October I got separated and now I had
every credit card in the world
that kept me going 91 92 selling neon a
little bit of coke a little bit of weed
you know me I'm a renaissance man
whatever you need to put together to pay
the bills just to keep you alive
you know in those days it's very easy
your rent is for your car payment's two
and a quarter you're cold you throw 100
away a week on groceries you don't want
to do something [__] I would add it
just like that from the junk why lie to
yourself that's how I start a [__]
month right when I was first got into
County my rent was 400. my car insurance
was 200. the car payment was like 129 or
something like that okay I I spent 100 a
week on [__] for the house what's that
fat tire yeah that'd be a fat tire right
English muffins [__] like that bread
with like [__] cheese American that's
all I had at that house okay I spent 200
a week on [__] food easy which is
really 800. why am I putting 200 there a
week let's face it 200 a week on food
okay easy we all do no I think he said
800 a week no no so I would say 12.
two three four fourteen hundred we need
another 500 for cocaine
two thousand dollars I'm really making
850 a month with my job we got to come
up and I would do it every month I would
make the [__] difference up the one
and I would put it on paper
even if I had to bring a lawnmower back
my first three years of Comedy would
come back comedy Jack I don't know what
the [__] you're talking about rent this
dude [__] what do we need to do here
right you know somebody who's gonna
announce that's grunted let's make one
move let's get out of this mess well you
actually said something the other day
that like blew my mind when you were
driving with Felicia and you're talking
about like everyone has four
goods and bads like the Cycles in their
life
and for some stupid reason in my mind
like I'm working I'm working right now
I'm like okay once I get to where I want
to be it's going to be smooth sailing
for the rest of my life and I I never
really understood that it's just
beginning
and like so like now now that you're
saying oh well sometimes the money
problems make people go home you're
always gonna have a bill like that's
that's when I'm slowly coming
we're not talking about well yeah I know
like when we're talking about
seven months in a row
of minus a thousand bucks
we're talking of
seven months in a row you're at the
store lingering you know I'm saying you
know what you're anger in your eyes
there's a linger in your eye you're
looking for food
a gig you're like what Bill am I gonna
pay do I pay this bill or do I pay this
bill what's the smartest move
and it's a it's a mindset and it breaks
people it almost broke me
I would have been broken
at what point
there was a couple situations where she
she bailed out that and Terry wasn't
making money guys
my wife was she was a waitress
three nights a week four nights a week
at the store at 400 a week that's 16 a
month
rent was seven the car payment
her school [__] you know
she was dead too we were both dead
but you know both of us helped each
other we always made the seven it was
600 rent I mean you know
so yeah but a [__] wouldn't get sick
of it that's 15 cents
that's 750 at The Improv and
twelve dollars whatever oh yeah 25 at
the Laugh Factory yeah and then Felipe
and Willie Barcena do you think it's
possible to have a day job out here as a
comedian sure I recommend it I recommend
it I did it I recommend it
it's not there's a point there's a point
where you can't have a day job no more
but but they'll let you know when that
point is it's because you're too busy
you're making too much so then why are
they minus a thousand
if they have a day job because everybody
wants to be [__] Leonardo DiCaprio
everybody wants to be an artist
everybody wants to live in Chelsea Hotel
oh well then it's their fault nobody
wants to do blows right drink like
[__] Jacks teller but they don't know
that that costs money every time you
don't go to work and you sit there with
that beautiful girl and you either [__]
and you tell stories and you go to chibo
and drop that 60 lunch that adds up
so I talked to Tommy Easter the other
day for example and I told Tommy used to
something that I found that that a lot
of people don't realize why you got a
job as a young comic in Los Angeles you
ready
if I'm at the point I'm at right now and
I have nine people helping me in
agencies and managers and I don't go out
for auditions which time he used to do
so I told Tommy you still to get a day
job something to supplement
you gotta supplement you know why
because it takes your head off this
nightmare one thing I learned uh from
acting class this guy I just sat in on
the class Aaron spiesner I think the
guy's name was
he goes you're gonna be an actor he's
like this is a business and if you're a
business you need startup Capital most
people don't think about it like that
yeah they're like oh I don't want to
have a job and do acting but it's like
you need startup Capital you need head
shots you need to do all that [__] they
make you jump through like remember when
you had to buy actual headshots Joey
[__] yeah you had to like spend money
you always have to spend money so it's
200 for the headshot then you take them
like an [__] to the age and he picks
11 pictures out each of those pictures
is eight dollars then you got to take
them back to them and then he orders
three of them and it was 300 headshots
for 99 if you went to La Brea and sunset
that was the best behind El Pollo Loco
and he would give you 69 plus 200 uh
business cards right you know but those
run out if those run out so every couple
months you got to go back and pay for it
they don't know about all those little
things and you gotta get wardrobe you
gotta [__] get gasoline you gotta do
all that [__] you can't do it without
income
and that's and not only that I want your
head to be fresh yeah because when
you're not working guess what you're
doing
you're at home thinking about what you
ain't got you're stressing when you're
not working you're at home thinking
about what you ain't got exactly I don't
give a [__] who you are when you're at
home wasting time in the daytime as a
[__] Joe artist I'm Joe artist I'm
gonna take watermelon juice and throw it
on the wall and it just signifies I get
it brother is this the Joe artist
originally but how are we gonna [__]
pay the rent how are we going to pay the
car payment listen go over with the
Agostino was and sell duct tape on the
phone you're still gonna walk out of it
with four or five hundred a week
part-time go to dog go over here on
Cahuenga you sell [__] ads for the
cops I know people who have no teeth who
smoke crack all night they walk out
there with 800 a [__] week so I'm
surprised more comics aren't Uber
drivers If You're Gonna Fly Comics are
Uber driver you're gonna [__] sit
there and just vegetate and write two
[__] jokes and tell yourself how good
you are that you're gonna make it with
this hot [__] blonde listen that
dream goes away fast I'll tell you what
I had a half hour special under my belt
[__] big tours lots of work uh tons
of TV appearances
2013 I still took a job I took a job
because I didn't want to be like how am
I going to get to the gig I took a
[__] job
and you know what I didn't I wasn't
happy about it but I did it we gotta
take a job man
I held the job till [__] 98.
and I got no problems with no qualms are
telling you people that
I started in 91 I held a job pretty much
till 98 I was selling cigars
I sold other [__] on Sunset they had
little offices everywhere and when I got
here there was a guy on Melrose two
blocks down from The Improv he paid 10
bucks an hour cash at the end of the day
cash
50 bucks you'd walk out of there you
walked in there well you know me I
walked in there at nine for what to call
[__] and make Insurance appointments
it was just a bunch of [__] desks and
if you got two an hour he gave me like
another 50 bucks and how many times I
walked in out of that two o'clock with a
hundred dollar bill in my pocket
whistling
and what was I going to do for a million
to two watch the news jerk off you're
gonna jerk off I could call him from
there I could use their fax machine
remember I tweeted you at like 7 A.M one
morning it was because I was at that job
and you called me up and you were like
dude you want to work in Irvine that's
because I was the only comic in L.A up
so I got the gig
that's right that's right but I'm
telling you my biggest advice I know
when I unless you listen you come out
here you sign with three yards yeah
they're gonna get you something to cover
the nut right you know there's
management companies that all they gotta
do is pick up the phone listen Lisa Aunt
[Music]
um
we have uh a standing
it's three weeks but it pays three G's a
week
yeah send them down I want them to see
what the set looks like the kids from
[__] Jersey never did nothing in his
life
so for three weeks later you go down and
make three G's you eat good food and now
at least it gets the ball going you got
an apartment
and even then let me see I'm with three
yards I'm with principal young I'm with
one of these big management companies
they get your job right through the door
that's what it is to be a manager
like listen all this is great but
what do we got today who can we call
today for a quick Richard Pryor said hey
that's really great but what are we
gonna do on Monday yeah
as in how am I getting paid this week
this is it and that's what the
I always knew I couldn't go back
like I knew I just wouldn't go back to
Boulder like a loser like that
and I wasn't going to go back to Jersey
and people were going to ask me hey so
what happened with stand up ah you know
it's rough out there and they want to
know because they want to they want to
justify the fact that they never left
and I'm gonna go back there and just
tell people for the rest of my life I
was in that I'm saying the movie
and that's it I don't even want to be
him saying like that was just one of my
years were people rooting against you do
you think not maybe not outright but
they do want to know that oh Taking
Chances doesn't work they kind of want
that confidence I wasn't going to go
home just it's in my DNA that I was just
not going to go home hit I was taking
something out of here Wing an arm a leg
I was taking something with me I knew
that going in because of the type of
personality I am and the people I had in
my life I had when I told people I was
involved in this I didn't tell nobody
for the first four years that's a smart
thing I did this very secretly it's like
when I went to jiu jitsu first three or
four months I didn't tell nobody
nobody needed to know let me see if I
like this before I go tell them people
I'm gonna be doing on bars and [__]
smarter than me people would be like my
first week doing open minds people there
what do you do I'm like oh I'm a
comedian I did comedy for maybe two
years I was awful I had a couple of
jokes you know
and I went home my friends asked me in
93 what are you doing tonight I'm trying
to do stand up and they go you know they
do stand up right down the block
and I'm like well I'm like I'm like oh
yeah yeah I know I'm going to say like
no no no
meet us there tonight
I get this like 20 of these [__]
Savages there snorting blow and the
guy's name was Gonzo we're still dear
friends until today was it because of
his nose no he just called him Gonzo he
runs a bunch of Comedy rooms in in
Jersey if you ever need work okay I'm
gonna call Gonzo yeah he's got them all
he's got one big show down the Jersey
sure
and I went up to him like hi my name is
Joe Diaz I've been doing comedy three
years and I got on the show because this
is a public access show
he goes it's just for professional
comedians man I'm sorry but give me your
number and I'll try to get Young
about 30 minutes later guy comes over he
goes hey man I'm putting you up for four
minutes at the end because your friends
threatened me hmm
she put me up nice and it was brutal
what I didn't know you want me to tell
you something I did well in front of my
friends because I made fun of my friends
right I talked about lebrano that he
stuttered and you know except when you
give him the crack pipe they don't
stutter and he's like [__] Pavarotti
singing Oscar Opera so they all laughed
and we got it and then I got their
support once they saw me kill
but my friends if they would have seen
me bomb the first time oh every time I
went against three drinks on how to stay
with a start on me but we just talked
about that you know that joke wasn't
that funny oh yeah they're those type of
people so see you had to do well I kept
them at Bay for a few years
because you need to get in there without
your friends and loved ones putting
their input in they might even tell you
not to do it at all so how do you do
Runner shows then if you can't tell your
love well you don't have to do bring
your shows that's number one I did them
in New York I did them here
and I brought some of my friends and
they go oh we liked it you were funny
but that guy at the end was really funny
that's the thing and it would bum me up
it's like oh hey my friends are here at
least and they're here supporting me
and Someday I'm gonna be that last guy
you know for some reason I never had
patience for anything
but when it got to Comedy since I hadn't
had patience with anything else
I started to get patience and I asked a
lot of questions and I kept my mouth
shut
and I but I knew all along that
everything else is [__] it's about
getting on stage
I'm happy you had it set
[Laughter]
I do
get on stage
and then
Comics asked me all the time how do we
how do I become a comedian right all day
get on stage every night easy
and well hard but
that's how you do it
you used to do with me are you [__]
kidding me or what
dropping it like a [__] here let
me get some shout outs here
Kevin for coming back and setting the
camera up and some albums on the wall we
got Santana Abraxas and Led Zeppelin too
and Sabbath Bloody Sabbath Def Leppard
high and dry
just in a [__] great job I want to
thank my man Jeremy slagoff my main
comic over there in [__] Vegas
tearing up Freddie Correa talking land
who I got a call I go to bed early every
night so I don't call him no more I used
to call him after midnight and talk [__]
with him like an hour Edward Spartan Pat
Shay and other [__] making it
happen with a real estate suit [__]
podcast
Peter mandibar I love you [__]
Aaron Heath Mark Thomas Aku Tessa pedino
no Tessa piano I love you [__] and
Chris Davila over there in Austin
keeping it down for us at least I got
you bad [__]
there you go you got me all depressed
you're not barking tonight I thought the
girl broke your heart no I was barking
from the street
[__] it Jack [__] it
so you're back now for how long yeah uh
indefinitely yeah you know this is my
home I wasn't even doing stand-up for
now since 1998
so 18 years this year
and how's it feel it feels good when I'm
on stage you know I feel like I got some
chops
you know I feel like I do something
special I'm going through Peaks and
valleys right now and I'm way in a
[__] deep deep hole with comedy I did
the same it's funny because when I was
up there on stage with Joe Friday night
the material sucked but my experience
got me through yeah yeah like I could
feel the experience getting me through
you know what I'm saying like it was
just weird can I ask you a question that
could you hear it it was echoing to you
as a performer because I've never been
backstage with like
at a theater like that and it was it was
like I don't know I don't think I could
have focused and been able to like it
was really coming back were you in the
audience though no I was backstage it's
completely different yeah theaters work
completely different
you know I'm thinking of shooting the
special and South Point was too big you
know and I had some ideas of where I was
gonna shoot it we had to change
everything today I was throwing a heart
and Ari was like what do you really want
to do you know where are you your best
and I narrowed it down to the
the best three comedy clubs that when I
get on stage five shows
it goes down like they get me from
beginning to end there's never like oh
or an eye or there's nobody politically
correct or
and I really want to do it in the comedy
club I don't want to do enough either
I'm not effective in a theater not at
all well it's a different thing it's
like when I go for Latin auditions when
I got a call and it's for Hector
and I can tell the agent Yeah Yeah Yeah
Yeah Yeah the more reason I go this is a
waste of a drive
but I'll tell you why because I have
zero confidence in actor as me playing
after
I might make it to producers because of
my chops right but once they look at me
they're looking for a certain type and
even though I may be Cuban and my last
name is Diaz I don't look like what
America perceives me as [__] actor
do you follow me all the way absolutely
so I know this going in it breaks my
heart when I have to call an agent back
and go hey man
I'm not going in for that so I tell them
right from the beginning don't send me
in for Latin auditions because I'll tell
you I'm gonna go
but that night after I smoke a joint I'm
afraid to go [__] yourself I'm gonna
look at where it is and realize traffic
and think about it you're a dead man you
talk to your agent like that you say
after I smoke a joint I'm gonna tell you
to go [__] yourself I asked him I asked
him a different way yeah
my commercial like I'm debating whether
they sign up with a commercial agent
right
but if anybody knows commercial
auditions they're a [__] painless
oh who's there oh [__]
uh
if you know anything about commercial
auditions they're really a [__] pain
in the ass sure they are it's a it's a
big uh
you gotta go and sign in and they're
running late and it's always on the
[__] Ocean Parkway there's 80
hectares there yeah you got to go down
there and then
so I was thinking about the other day
I'm like ah
but it also gets you out of the house
it's part of what we do it's a number
sure you know that's you never know who
you're gonna meet you never felt like
you did something sometimes you go to a
stupid commercial dishes you bump into
people I like going over the one over La
Brea that's the best commercial spot
because I go downstairs to Petco I pick
up a little something for the cats while
I'm waiting it's not a waste of a
[__] day well you're always gonna see
some ass there and a comic you know oh
no there's always and it's funny because
when that kid won the Oscars
from Modern Family the chubby gay guy
yeah at the end of his speech he said I
just want you to know
this is called from my agents I went to
every audition I was sent on even Ocean
Avenue on a Friday afternoon right
that's how common it is when people are
going we're not going down there and
Ocean Avenue is very easy it's four or
five to the ten in the way back it's a
[__] nightmare cause you got to come
up with that bridge there's an
earthquake you start thinking about San
Francisco against the Oakland [__]
whatever it's a couple hours getting
home it's a couple hours to get home
especially on the Fridays I used to work
all all the only time only work in La
for where TV is in Santa Monica like 90
of it so you just get stuck I would just
stay and watch movies yeah that's the
move that's the move and that's why even
like Damon was always smart when Damon
was always unemployed he always stayed
busy
[__] I'm collecting unemployment I'm at
home smoking dope all [__] day
but if you don't do something you won't
generate work
that's the thing sometimes if you don't
have any work just and you don't even
have a spot you just go out to the
Improv or the store next thing you know
you're working that week and right away
we're back to nothing happens on the
couch nothing happens on the camera yeah
I'm on the computer sending out resumes
your [__] what's his name quadrant
intelligence in the set go down and eat
lunch for free yeah you're gonna bump
into somebody you know and they're gonna
go hey man I didn't know you weren't
working I'm shooting a movie next week
and there you are going Jesus Christ I'm
gonna sit home and tape afford Apache
the Bronx and watch that for lunch with
a tuna fish sandwich I don't nothing
happens on that [__] couch but the
universe will give you back sometimes
the universe the other day we were
talking about giving you the universe a
big
sometimes the universe gives you that
big back it's like putting money in the
bank sometimes
sometimes out of somewhere the [__]
it just repays you some of you you're
bump into and go hey man didn't you
shoot that video with me about a year
ago yeah we sold it
give me five minutes I'll give you a
check and you're like holy [__] yeah
just because you went out that night or
did something I went out one night years
ago broke
97 broke
broke I send that one of those uh
backstage stupid things right backstage
comes out here on Wednesdays yeah most
people buy it on Thursdays I was always
ahead of you I came Thursday at five
Wednesday at five I was there about
Wednesday about 6 30 7 11 cursing
I would run home dude that's where I
used to live
and you run back home and I'd fill out
those things
or I'd bring it back go out get Coke and
do a spot and get Coke and come back and
stay up till four and I do like eight
submission you know what if you send
them out Thursday they get them Friday
right and they call you for an audition
on Saturday they don't have big budgets
on those I'll never forget that I went
for one of those and on the way I think
it was come here for a second give me a
name write it down here you're not right
for this because this is gonna suck I'll
never forget this is Saturday at Gardner
stages downstairs where at the end of
the audition they sat us down and said
by the way we're giving you each of
paperwork the only way you get booked in
this movie is if you get Investments
that was 97 98th that's how crazy this
town was down how much of an investment
did they want five thousand to start
it started at five thousand to get a
roll and you had to audition and after 5
000 the bigger the more your donations
the bigger the road got
so people actually trying to get
investors that were the actors in this
movie I don't forget that and me going
what are you [__] crazy
so how do these people who run these
scams sleep at night uh the way I could
do the assistant to the dude pulled me a
sign language listen I'm shooting
something next week you're [__]
perfect for it write down your number
and I thought it was [__] sure
enough 11 o'clock Saturday night calls
me up she goes listen man can I meet you
tomorrow by The Coffee Bean on Sunset I
go sure I thought he was like a creepy
gay guys would suck my dick or something
legal confidentiality agreement
okay I signed them then he goes you're
gonna be working with two actors
well-known actors
you can't repeat this you're gonna shoot
a scene from a movie so we can get
foreign investment
you're gonna pay the clap you're gonna
pay a New York City cab driver
I'm like okay when do I do it he goes
right now we're gonna go get your
wardrobe follow me in your car
want to get your wardrobe and it shoots
tonight at one in the morning downtown
like it was Hush [__] hush no permits
you're saying no everything was on the
level cops but they didn't want nobody
to know what these people were shooting
this
so it's like maybe six people in the
shoot
and they gave me uh it was two nights I
think they gave me 500 bucks a night or
something I had one line
and when I got there it was Michelle
Pfeiffer
and uh the dude who was a Jamie bond for
a while
good looking dude that had the show
Timothy Hutton no can you say this
Pierce Bronson Pierce Bronson
it was 1998 it was going to happen it
was gonna happen Okay and it was a movie
about
she's an actress
a well-known actress and he's a theater
reviewer
and he gives her a bad review and that
was it was like a love story based on
that thing right and I picked them up at
the theater and dropped them all for he
gets in the cab they get to an argument
that was it I shot the first night
the second night they wired the cab we
did the inside I got home like at six in
the morning
they [__] paid me cash no excuses no
mailing address they just started
peeling off hundreds
I went home and I never heard another
[__] thing I never saw the movie
developed so
obviously it didn't get made so that's
why I could talk about it but if I
wouldn't have gone to that Saturday
morning on audition at nine o'clock
I would have never got that
yeah do you follow me I was when we were
talking about couch would you bring
Damon oh oh [__]
oh [__]
Damon showed up dozen donuts well you
did kettlebells today you could [__]
kill it you can have about eight of them
I'm trying to be good were you trying to
be good well trying ain't gonna work for
you tonight you know what I'm saying did
you guys hear about the uh the crazy
thing people are doing to fast food
restaurants what what it happened all
over it happened last like a couple
nights ago in like Minnesota they're
calling and pretending to be the uh fire
department saying there's a gas leak and
we need you to break your windows or
else your building is going to explode
there's a video of this of the all the
employees smashing the windows in the in
the [__] manager rammed his car into
the building
and it's like over like six different
fast food restaurants costing like ten
thousands of dollars worth of damage
it's just for sport yeah hilarious
people work for Indians
so people were saying like hurry up we
just got to call from the fire
department break all the [__] Windows
yeah I hope this is a fake story I think
it's real I thought it's the guardian
it's a real story demon okay thank God I
don't want to get those uh let me check
they did in a bunch of places they did
it
in Tucson
they did in Phoenix
and they didn't like uh Marina Bay
California and I think it was Minnesota
it was this one
so they've done like people are just
somehow convincing them that they need
to break all the windows
[__] hilarious
Matt Voltron why the depression someone
talk to him oh wow I know I'm tired of
[__] I told you I've been doing my I do
all I've done since I got back is work
on my taxes
which [__] ultimately I'm wondering
what's the bill gonna be I don't want to
pay it whatever it is I don't want to
pay it
and so I'm worn out from the calculator
and the receipts and this and that I've
also been getting up early that's not my
style
[__] worn out Joey
that's all I can tell you you know what
brother it gets easier
paying your dues when that's all that
fun no I mean the reason why the reason
why I'm not looking forward to this is
because I had a good year last year
which means this is the time of year you
hate you hate when you had a good year
you wishing you had a bad year all of a
sudden like God damn it really that yeah
and you you get the bill I can't believe
how much they want and even after
deductions and the guy always saves you
20 bucks you know I can't just save me
some more [__] yeah I know you know what
take that [__] [__] out of there
throw me that pen Damon over there I
don't have a 91 I was working right
before I got [__] divorced
I was working for my in-laws and
I haven't like the year before I made
good money like legally guys like I
curbed some [__] cars I worked as an
estimator they paid me good money and
what I paid [__] this like that that
pushed me over the top like the first
time like I was like I can't believe
they didn't take taxes out right away or
you calculated that no they were paying
me like
900 a week then they 10.99 me at the end
of the year
you got the bill for half oh for half of
what they gave you
and there's still potholes and the first
year I paid it but after I got divorced
that year yeah and ripped that
[__] up I'm like I'm not sending
this in yeah and I got a return from
them that year and then the following
year I'm like you know what I said
nothing to no more and I didn't send
taxes in from 91 to
2003. did they ever call you yeah yeah
they called me I heard a [__] ghost
dog
listen there's a way to live and there's
a way not to live
I could teach you how to be a [__]
ghost
did you not hear me say I didn't get
mail at my house
what do you where do you get it I would
get it over at Gavin's house all right
in those days so I lived on Schrader I
lived I lived in the other side of
Hollywood but I got mail on Shredder so
the Gathering it calls for you no and I
put like a fake number you call my
number in those days unless you're an
employer
it was very rough to have my number
because it all went through a pager I
went through a page with my friend I
screamed everybody like a [__] I
heard
a club owner recently told me and I'm
not gonna mention any names
There's a comic on stage
he's headlining he's in the first two or
three minutes of his set
somebody walks up to him and hands him a
piece of paper
and says you just been served
for child support
my man got [__] busted and served on
stage and he still had to do like 42
minutes
[Laughter]
let me tell you something you have you
guys have no idea what it's like to owe
every credit card I don't in those days
I used to be an open mic
MC at the broker on Tuesday nights
and I dated the owner's daughter now
when I started caving in owing money
there was no worse feeling I had when I
started caving up like the first day I
couldn't make the first credit card
payment
yeah it destroyed me it destroyed me and
it went into five days because usually
give you five days there was no five
days it went to ten days and I knew I
was done I just went through all of them
I had 19 different people calling me but
I'll never forget a specific night when
I got there
and the girls that was dating came up to
me and gave me a sheet of paper she goes
this guy keeps calling here from
American Express
you know says you owe money or something
I was never so [__] embarrassed right
like this guy got my [__] number
at dude same thing happened to me about
three years ago and they started calling
my family because full Sharon ain't
exactly a common name
so my folks my brother they're pretty
easy to find
that's [__] embarrassing too
a couple years ago I'm shooting I go
down to Hollywood
some [__] jerk off tells me to go to
this dentist
I go to this dentist he does me a solid
and I go back again
he breaks me on the root canal no no he
breaks me he goes listen
you need a root canal I don't do root
canals like what the [__] you talking
about
he goes you gotta go down the block
there's a guy waiting for you down the
block right now I already called him
he'll do the root canal I said okay
and I got sag insurance I go down in
root canal
whole [__] thing
whatever the [__] you pay up front
whatever the [__] you paid copay and
that's it you go home and they bill you
and then we got a bill from these idiots
never got a built from this [__]
my wife called they said they sent it or
whatever we never got it do you know I'm
[__] shooting a commercial a Sprint
commercial and my phone's buzzing I pick
it up but it's a collection agency
they mailed the [__] check to the
wrong place
and they just took me right the [__]
Collections and I'll call them once or
anything
and here I am on the [__] set
of a Sprint commercial getting
embarrassed on my own and this
[__] kept calling me you know
what he called me and my agent you know
what he did he got my agent's number and
he called me they have a way now
to get Lee's number and call me from
Lee's number a burner so you'll pick
misdirection yeah you'll pick it up and
they'll go
jodias it's Damon you all American
Express eight thousand dollars like I
thought this was Elite that's how
[__] Cricket the best part is about
calling you though is even if it's your
friend you're gonna go what's up
[__] so at least you're starting
the conversation off right no no no no I
got him because they just call looking
for Jose
ah
expect some guys saying oh you go hello
King Island I'm like hello and then like
it's just Jose Diaz and I go no it's not
well he gave this number this ain't
those ideas dog let me ask you something
do I sound like [__] Jose DSD don't
call this [__] number no more and
they disappear it's beautiful it's like
[__] poetry in motion yeah I need to
change my name yeah Jose Diaz with the
accent so if they call you looking for
[__] Maria Consuelos you know they
were expecting things
yet [__] you just talk to them like
this what's going on guys there's no
Jose here do I [__] hear guitar music
in my [__] house no what name do you
use when they do call me
but you know like I'm not Jose I'm Mike
George I don't say nothing you're not
supposed to say
the less you pay are you Jose it doesn't
really matter
I'm not Jose what is your name it
doesn't really matter does it don't call
this number no bro bro
[__] favor what's wrong with you do
us both of you and don't stop because
they're like they'll tell the boss this
isn't him I just called it's a [__]
white dude that sounds like as well
soprano
Jose Diaz he's a Spanish dude no
so I throw him the [__] off what do you
think you're dealing with guys
come on come on I've done it who's
better than you Joey I've done it the
cops like Jose did no no
what's your name my Ferguson where's
your idea my friend's car what friend
Matt Fulton where is he I don't [__]
know he's on cursive he's at 7-Eleven I
went to either his house last night he
took the [__] car and what do you
think I'm doing here stuck why do you
think I'm [__] here because I want to
be here officer and you start talking
just sell it but you gotta sell it if
you don't sell it you're not gonna get
nowhere
listen they caught me in a hotel room
stealing in San Francisco and I talked
to two cops out of it so chasing the
[__] maid I went into her room with
her keys she went they went to go in
that room I locked the top [__] Lop
on them they went and got the cops I was
in the third floor I couldn't jump off
the [__] building I talked the
[__] cops out of I was running down
the hallway and I took the house and the
maid chased me
but I didn't want to [__] prosecute
I've been in the building for a month
you have no [__] idea but you got to
sell it you got to keep [__] selling
it
wasn't gonna take me down for
fingerprints now they got me but even
now I'm not giving you dick you
understand me even that I won't break
you ever see Rambo in the second one
when the Russian had the big knife and
they said I put the [__] thing in
your eyeball he didn't break the
Japanese chick shot under the building
and saved them but you never break you
just keep riding that [__]
that's why you're good at auditioning
right away yeah even when they show you
the paperwork
even when they show you the paperwork
you can I'm still fighting it I don't
know what that is would you say the cops
again to get out of it which one in San
Francisco I told them that the maid that
had taken towels from the truck and the
maid Chase man she was really mean
uh-huh and I ran into the [__] room
to hide
and I thought she was gonna go away and
that's when I was going to sneak out but
in fact they came back with the cops
right cops listen to my story The ncic I
told them I lived in the building the
landlord came up and said hey no problem
he's been here for like three months
this has never happened before right
that he let me go the landlord came over
to me goes this wouldn't be with who's
robbing what's his name there was a
bookie in the building I'd clean him out
every Monday
he had those football tickets like an
old guy he never before 500 bucks that
was a chump you know
so that's when he put it together and I
left
no I didn't leave I stayed there and the
next night he knocked on the door and he
goes hey I just got the call from the
San Francisco police I want to know if
you're still here the people with
Germans and they went to the Embassy and
told their story and complained
so they called the police department so
they're not going to come to arrest you
for burglary but there was nothing
missing from their room
so that's why they couldn't arrest me at
first so now the Germans got so mad I
was in their room
that they were going to come and arrest
me so by the time the cops got there to
arrest me I was on the bus to [__]
Reno Jack
right around the corner Jose Diaz
[__] enroute to Reno like a [__]
doctor
it's crazy but you have to sell it now
you're dead
now they take it to the sea in the old
days you went down and got fingerprinted
unless you stabbed somebody in the eye
it wasn't a priority it went into a
stack
why is it different nowadays everything
is on computer right as soon as you put
your fingerprint on this in the old days
they took ink and you put your finger on
and then you put it on a piece of paper
right and you did this you put a piece
of paper in today's world once you put
your [__] four fingers on that pad
everybody gets alerted it's the fastest
credits right right you have no [__]
idea how those fingerprints go through
the system instantly and they start
picking up little things now it's a
complete different world now they have a
problem with identity they just say
listen you're going to the station
well listen don't worry my math
voltron's car and his license we're not
going for it no more come on yeah they
take it to the station they put your
fingers on there ask you if you say who
you are are you the full charge are you
the full charge
I mean no no the sheet comes right in
front of you right and it's the kid who
robbed my identity who [__] he used
the the bank card he got arrested one
time and he used my name
and the cops knew he's Italian and
they're like so your name is Jose Diaz
he's like yeah
he kept saying that they came back he
said they came back with a scroll
and then I give you all those ideas let
me tell you a little bit about yourself
they just started dropping charges on
them where I had warrants put on a pot
of coffee after about 20 minutes he saw
a yelling no
I'm not Jose yes
now it's amazing what's on the computer
now but I know for a fact a lot of the
things I did early on disappeared
there's so many things that disappeared
in the beginning they never made it to
the computer never made it to the
computer
thank God
well does it still affect you the thing
that destroys me was the car
what car I left the car one time
I walked away from the card name and you
know me I don't [__] around Damon I went
to start it the elect I smelt some smoke
I heard
I [__] turned the car off dog and
walked away and walked away went to the
train took the train I said [__] I'll
come back in three days wrong answer by
the time I got there was a skeleton it
was a [__] skeleton yeah I didn't
call the bank I didn't call the cops I
was 19. well I give a [__]
Endeavor never did I hear word one
not word one about that car no credit
report
no nothing did you have payments on it
or was it yours and you just didn't call
anybody no I just went to Colorado right
I just picked up a month later moved to
Colorado I got time for this [__] about
cops and doing paperwork in those days I
didn't believe it none of that [__] next
time you're on set you're gonna get a
call from New Jersey
I got another car you'll be doing a
Chrysler Commercial
is this Jose Diaz I got another call one
time
when I'm gonna get into specifics I was
a little crazy I just got divorced I
said I'm gonna get a [__] badass car
in Boulder
I got a badass [__] call with uh
with uh us a tremendous sound system and
a CD player
and I went and bought a bunch of CDs and
[__] and I ran this car
like a Savage I did 90 everywhere
and the snow and finally I bashed up the
[__] ring
and I was gonna rob a dealership and
take one of their cars and switch the
rims because the rims are two thousand
dollars a piece that's stock
and I ruined two of them so I was down
Four G's I hadn't made a payment on this
car in six months I had to put the car
in the garage under a [__] tarp up
those under a tarp you have no idea
everybody was looking for this car
and one night I'm sitting there
scratching like a [__] junkie
and I'm like I gotta get a package
because for me to get my dick sucked
from this girl I gotta show up with a
package right you know it's just life
even if it's a little package
and I said well and I wanted my drawer
and there was Jackson discover
oh yeah
if they send you when you get the car
and you can just write checks with them
make their money and let me tell you
something I hadn't paid that Discover
card
and like 120 days and I took that check
and I wrote it out for a thousand bucks
yeah and I took my [__] chances but
little did I know I forgot it was the
same track it was the same bank where I
took the car going for
Okay so
this Avatar and I have people it's just
to let you know you know uh you're not
dealing with no [__] genius here and
I
it's 12 o'clock at night the bank is
open till I'm lying to you guys the bank
is open till 12 on Saturday nights
I'm gonna [__] with that world I'm gonna
show up with this check at 10 to 12.
I show up at the check I write my
account number
I put the check in
all of a sudden they go
Mr Diaz how do you want this
I go I don't know because I told him I'm
gonna put 500 in the account just give
me 500 cash
all I needed was 100 bill
to get my party started
this [__] looked back to me she goes so
how much do you want to put in the
account I'm like well how much do I need
to put in here because just a hundred
we'll give you 900 cash give me the
[__] nine hundred dollars
I tore out of there I went and got an
eight ball I went right to the broker I
got [__] lit that Monday at 901 my
[__] phone rang and it was the bank
going hey dog listen
we got a [__] problem
we could call the cops on this
but we're not we're going to keep this
in-house
we need you here one hour and 900 cash
so just bring a bunch of coke dog that
wasn't a dime left
that was nothing I had so many things
going on yeah please bro yeah yeah it
was like Robin Peter the people did you
get laid yeah and I walked into the bank
and when he goes no we're gonna do is
just tack it on to your bank one
let's track it on to the uh the car loan
is it this Bank stayed up till midnight
on Sunday on Saturdays Fridays and
Saturdays so they're up to some shady
[__] too
it gets better about this bank but hold
on that car I had to drive that car to
do comedy and that's it besides that it
was like I'm telling you it was in a
[__] garage closed blocked with two
cars the people who lived in the
apartment with me
that car finally got [__] up I was
gonna put the rims on and when I left I
just told them he'll pull that side
they'll be here I mean we didn't it
wasn't outside
three seconds yeah and [__] everybody
was there looking for that car it was
amazing they had binoculars it was
[__] crazy
and I was so happy the moral of the
story is do you know I've never heard
about that car again
really never came back I'm never alone
you think that's because of the bank was
so [__] cool well that same bank
about a year later
ready for this one yeah the
drive-through was very popular okay I
had a lot of drive-throughs oh yeah so
some [__] genius
because only a genius does this fight
with your teeth
people carrying guns and the stupid
people Rob people for the wrong reasons
this guy robbed it but he's planned them
he went to they had like six Lanes
and he went to three other lanes and he
put a color for them
with the women
in the window
don't you think that after an hour or
two you wonder why isn't somebody going
down my Lane
yeah and then they put a sign that said
the window is broken please put deposits
in the Box
and they cleaned them up the bank didn't
know for six hours
and only Gentiles there's only trusting
white people just hand the money over
outside no deposit slip because come on
how many times do you go to the bank at
least get a deposit this list yeah no
deposit that he even wrote something on
that well email you the deposit slip by
the time you get back to your house
something [__] ridiculous right they
had that place surrounded with [__]
duct tape they fingerprints and
everything nothing it was like an
unsolved mystery in both they estimated
the guy walked out of there with nine
grand listen it's peanuts but it's nine
more Grand than I had than yesterday you
know what I'm saying oh [__] no [__]
weapon involved no nothing all you're
gonna do is come on yeah that's great
that's genius yeah it's brilliant he
could he could have done it for longer
like he could have been more money
I wonder if we stayed and watched
like I just imagined how would you
translate that today like an ATM machine
like go right over here to Lankershim
and put two signs and said put this in
this metal box and screw it into the
wall so they can see it screw it into
the wall
that's how many people would leave that
money in that box I don't think it's
much and run it all day Monday like on a
Monday no Friday
when people have the lines that I
guarantee people get off the lines and
go why are we waiting on here it says to
drop this money in here do you think
they do it out here I was gonna say
maybe anyway with this Gentiles they're
looking around thinking that everything
is beautiful
you know those people are walking around
oh my God life is great the whole
[__] deal yeah those are people that
don't actually they need the money on
the check well they do
but they're not paying attention right
what's in front of them they never
really
you know every year how many old people
get robbed on the phone by people
calling them up and making Investments
on them a lot it's the oldest [__]
scam in the book yeah you know
uh how many people we all get an email
once a week from Africa oh yeah our
friend of ours I got stuck at the
airport and they need money quickly lost
their wallet give them your number and
he'll gladly pay you when he returns to
the States you know you know these
people got [__] set of balls but yeah
he emails 150 people somebody it's a
mass marketing it's Mass marketing yeah
take those guys on Twitter hi my buddy
got hit for and I want to call GoFundMe
okay you know Joey I'm when they said
when they don't even mention my name I
know they're lying right okay what you
do is go to that page
and if the last three days all they've
been sending it out and retweeting Matt
Voltron yeah at least I had retweet
Damon's wicker retweet that's a scam you
know I got contacted on Twitter and that
was it that was it that was the last
time I gave to a GoFundMe unless I
personally personally personally know
the people
because I got in trouble because I gave
money yeah and I think they made like
what they do is they set it up for
[__] one day listen man they pulled
down three bills there's three bills in
but there's something weird like they
pick up the money that it's supposed to
I don't know how the [__] it works but
still who gives a [__] you give them
money they do with the 10 different
accounts they set up like 10 different
accounts and they get 10 pictures of
people getting hit by different cars and
they put them out there and they put a
picture with a cane whatever the [__]
you got and suckers like me and you send
the guy 50 bucks well speaking of taxes
there's like the IRS scam that gets
called that you gotta call you're you're
gonna get audited you're gonna go to
jail you have to wire this this amount
of money like I saw some post on
Facebook about people are getting these
calls all the time anytime somebody
wants money and you click on something
I say [__] that I go right to the
website the website that I know somebody
tried to hit me up with PayPal the other
day and they were like we need you to
log in because there's some some
irregular activity on your PayPal
account and I didn't [__] log in on
that I went to the real PayPal site
everything was [__] yeah
I said I told you the other night I
don't click on
[Laughter]
I'm gonna be as honest as I can on the
podcast right now I don't click okay
let me tell you how to start Tuesday let
me tell you how this is and I love you
all
but let me tell you how this starts
people
I click on the Yahoo I put my code and I
click on the uh from Yahoo I look at the
first five sentences and anything you
know anything about it if it's nothing
that got to do with me I click right on
top man
it's an Hotmail go to Facebook and for
Facebook I go to Twitter
then I go to Gmail if Gmail ain't got
nothing for me I click that and I put
YouTube in
and that's it
so
if you send me a link
the league you get playing the drums
it's not gonna get hit I'm just letting
you people know right now Twitter
Facebook YouTube the message gets erased
unless I personally know you I don't
touch nothing
don't touch nothing I don't give nobody
codes
I don't give a [__] shut it down [__]
let's see
it's all Islam you wake up once a week
There's a [__] scam from Facebook or
something nothing I don't I don't click
on I just erase them and take my chances
do you add anybody on Facebook because I
do and it's it always bites me in the
ass like if someone wants to be my
friend I'll let I'll say yeah
and then the next thing you know there's
like advertisement for Nikes
I mean I got a screening process but
still
well anybody that's really hot is really
actually a dude I know most of people I
don't think I can take no more people on
Facebook like a Facebook lock you down
it's all [__] so
I just have to be friends with people or
something I don't [__] know I don't
[__] know nothing I just keep a light
on that [__] I don't know yeah I totally
every day I'm gonna tell you who
harasses me that I can press charges on
Lincolnton Lincolnton harasses me every
[__] day if I was a half a Jew I'd
get Lincoln them and take them to court
and then now they push the soap B what
do they call themselves The Social
Network it's a bunch of bums that aren't
working that want to come invade your
[__] privacy like right in 85 I don't
want these [__] kisses of Death
Around we were just talking about kisses
to death I don't want these people
around so stop hitting me up on Lincoln
I'm not even opening up that account
professionals you're a [__] [__] you
ain't no [__] professional I don't
[__] with linking them Instagram that's
my daughter that's my dog Mikey podcast
101 I can't take pictures
I'm not gonna take pictures all day and
send them to people that's not gonna
[__] happen right I'm not gonna sit
there and take pictures I can't I'm too
old you tweet every day I tweet in the
morning okay I tweet in the morning if
you tweet that you're going to be in
Wisconsin I retweet it for you because
it's my family right but I don't do it
for everybody else there's certain
people
because if not people think of the
energy the next thing you know you're
between your whole [__] life I don't
want to retweet all day you gotta have a
positive thought on that yourself yeah
or something [__] up Lee how many
donuts only when I had a blueberry when
I was delicious did you really leave you
can't wait to get that box home tonight
you're gonna tear those money no what'd
you do with those two dollars I give
them to the mom did you love them
uh I'm still I'm only back down to 2 30.
I [__] up for a little bit that went
up to like 235. you look thinner than
before man no he looks very good
so you've been going three days a week
for how many weeks in a row like five or
six weeks looking God bless
the protein powder from Dolce you're a
new [__] man
Donuts
you're a funny [__] thank you
man I appreciate what's on the goddamn
Horizon for me let me see what other
Donuts you gotta make cause I'm stoned
that [__] edible in that hash killed
me look at that he brought Maple Donuts
we'll [__] kill him in here I'm gonna
take one of these little jokes
what's in here lemon I don't know told
him give me some
dinner
that's good news apparently oh [__] is
that what you had late no I didn't know
I haven't had a regular blueberries like
the blueberry muffin one scrape being a
[__] Stoner though you got no
self-control yeah there's nothing you
can do that's the hardest part you can't
get full either no you don't and when
you start and especially something sweet
you're [__] because especially when
you do good all day and then [__]
Damon the sweetheart brings two dozen
donuts over you like you want to kill
yourself because it's like so hard to
say no yeah that's a bad hangover a
donut hangover no it's the most
delicious one
I used to get when I was like 315 I just
get a half a dozen donuts and be like
yeah and just eat them within a day not
not within the sitting but with another
day ah six donuts what's that right
what's that what's that for breakfast
I'm good man I ain't into sweets
you guys go crazy to get into sweets
because Damon brought the [__] Goods
of death of him all right I did some
kettlebells today I got some sun out
there I did some sugar some 25 pound
kettlebell thanks man
what are you gonna do I'm gonna turn
them down I don't give a [__] tomorrow's
another day we start from scratch
I go to Jujitsu tomorrow at lunch time
that's how we do it that's it nobody
gets that feeling inside Lisa yeah no at
least you're trying no that's it you
went to class today oh yeah and you
fought for your [__] life I'm gonna
eat another one because I don't give a
[__] it was a good class what's that
what's that third one yeah who's
counting
and I don't even have dinner
come on leave
quit being a [__] and come on
wait there's a maple syrup donut and you
know that all you know that
old-fashioned staring in the face
where they're from
Magnolia
yeah this is like one of the best shows
I've ever done you know why because this
is as simple as it gets there's no drama
there's no
facetious people trying to be [__]
you know trying to make you feel bad we
smoke dope and you make mistakes
and you eat good sometimes you eat bad
some deji good night good all day
what do you have
open it
no bread
I didn't eat good today at all I could
tell
a slice of pizza
that's good for breakfast Frozen Trader
Joe's chow mein God knows what the [__]
that is and then a yucca's Taco on the
way over here
which is borderline let's just
borderline but now with the donut
it's officially a bad day it's right in
uh Los Feliz like right on uh Hollywood
after Hollywood starts to curb what kind
of Taco did you get I got a steak taco
get off the hook yeah it's delicious add
oatmeal I had a fruit smoothie with
almond milk
believe it or not I'm really liking
those
and a mixed berry one with cherry
you know for breakfast it's got high
sodium so you take a gigantic [__]
and then what I have for lunch I had a
chicken cutlet sodium make you [__] is
that right not sodium well the other
word I don't know whatever when you have
the other fiber and then I my food went
to the restaurant last night and she
brought chicken parmesan and it was the
smallest piece I had that was it
I shot to my meeting I didn't eat down
there they had food there like animals
and then when I got home I had something
else
she made steak with a baked potato oh
nice and I ate half the baked potatoes
she cuts the steak into little cubes
like Medallion so I'm gonna [__] with it
and she recooks it for me now usually I
put it over white bread I didn't put it
over white bread I like the grease from
the steak to go into the white bread
you're following me that's what I'm
professional does it but I didn't take
it to the Limit like that
the Damon shows up with the best donuts
in the [__] world once I got 300
milligrams of me Edibles we got refill
we got hash you can't show up with
donuts you gotta show up like apples but
hey at least he's like the three wise
men he showed up with something you know
what I'm saying right you can't be mad
at them for that so I'm pretty [__]
happy people get down on themselves and
they I don't you know you know why
because I won't go get another donut we
went the other night and got one [__]
donut but we drove for four [__]
hours you know on the way back we could
exercise we could have gone together we
could have we could have gone to a
[__] bar or something well you're not
like it sounds stupid but that was hard
for me to have two Donuts in my house
because I fought you I didn't want to
take those ones to my house because I
thought I was gonna eat them well
Felicia bought a half a dozen
so she comes back with a [__] half a
dozen go buy one a piece I can live with
one [__] dog it's like a sociable you
know what I'm saying it's like you can't
eat a lot of donuts because the cops are
out you can't drink beers right because
the cops are out right you can't have
three beers so one Donut's always good
nobody gets that feel listen if you ate
two Donuts every [__] day for
breakfast
there's not enough sit-ups you can
[__] do in the world
but two Donuts twice a week especially
on workout days because I look at it
this way
let's be honest here
when I was really smoking though
I wouldn't even shed that box with these
[__] [__] you understand oh
I can look down there I would have done
eight I could do eight of those I can't
lie you want me to lie they did that
this week with a nice bag of chips
[__] up the fantasy no because you do
because that's salty yeah
[__] sit there with a chocolate shake
with the remote control oh my God and
you get that box and you open that
[__] Savage up and you got a bong
next to you or a little container and
you look at that box and you say we're
going deep right
and that's it that's too much then you
go running for 14 hours what too much
sugar you ate [__] three tacos and
two other things you told me you you
[__] McDonald's menu oh yeah it was
terrible my head almost flew how much
sodium do you think you went to sleep at
night with oh a thousand two thousand
[__] grams same thing but these you
know listen man I'm just saying to you
in for my mouth that me too sweet
for your [__] would it be too sweet
tooth I can't you must check gray if you
have a bunch of donuts and milkshakes
tremendous it's smooth yeah a nice
vanilla shade thing okay Breyer's ice
cream some good [__] holes ice cream
and a milkshake oh you're talking about
how you make it no come on dog a little
[__] Brian's ain't me wash down this
ice cream with some milkshake in this
day and age Hey listen there was no
[__] uh there was no diabetic
packages in my house there was only real
cane sugar like a [__] that went
on my milkshakes in those days there's
two types of milkshake there's healthy
milkshakes and there's milkshakes to
make you see the devil the healthy
milkshakes you put the eggins protein
powder and eight ounces of milk and you
put a little bit of [__] ice cream
and you put wheat Grand wheat grass in
there are you supposed to be in a
Purgatory huh it's like being in
purgatory but you you want those Devils
but then you have those devil milkshakes
that's just pound for pound milk ice
cream and sugar that's it that's it
that's it takes you with a box of those
[__] donuts with like the mechanic on
with Charles Bronson are you [__]
serious oh yeah who's gonna stop you
[__] nobody nobody [__] sucker
I think I'm gonna stop by on Wednesday
whether I got a spot or not I won't be
there Wednesday this week I'm only there
Thursday and [__]
Saturday I'm in Vegas on Thursday where
are you at in Vegas uh forget I'm
opening up for your boy Tommy Segura no
[__] yeah yeah yeah
uh I'm gonna be in Spokane after that
with Tommy too
uh the week after that
it's gonna be a good time
you're doing it man oh yeah no that's
about it it's weird when you see like uh
a bum like me I got the wife and the kid
now
and now I look at like the other day uh
you follow what's going on in the UFC
the other day Chris Weidman I don't know
and the other guy had a chit chat he
told me you can't be as good as me
because you have a family
that's not always true though all your
time goes into your family you don't
have no responsibilities and whatever
but it kind of is because
I wish I'd go on the road I wish I'd go
to Vegas
and have to be in New York the next week
I wouldn't stay in Vegas I'd go to New
York early and stick around for three
days no I do all kinds of [__] you know
I can't do that I have children you know
and I wish I did you know I'm happy I do
you know what I'm saying I mean trust me
my plan my original plan tonight
was to go see David Gilmore you guys do
know that like for the last three months
what happened
I had a meeting today at 12 o'clock that
I couldn't reschedule again until like
May 14th or something [__] just May
10th or something crazy yeah
I felt that if these people worked this
hard to get me meetings
if something happens you cancel it but
not because I'm gonna [__] drop two
thousand dollars out of my family's
money to go see Pink Floyd right David
Gilmore right do you know what I'm
saying like I [__] up when he came
here and he wasn't here so you're gonna
go out of town to see him I was going to
go out of town I really my plan was
really to go home and see my buddy James
and little Timmy and I think a villa was
gonna go and then this other guy at
fokarachio but then when they hit a folk
he said he couldn't go he had to go out
of town for business yeah and then James
was gonna go the whole time he was going
to go alone and he's gone to all those
concerts alone which is with your kids
I talked to a villa last week and he was
like I'm not going which shocked me
shocked me because he was the one that
took me to see the wall oh yeah like I
went to see the wall with a villa
folkarachio no [__] Jimmy lebrano Jimmy
lebrano outages day one he's he's just
got a job driving a truck for 22.50 an
hour so he's like I ain't doing [__]
right I got to be on time at this time
cake so then it was down to us three
folks said he was out Villa said he was
out now my buddy James that's my brother
I would have gone with him it wouldn't
have made a difference
but then I realized I had the meeting on
that [__] thing yeah like you know
and then today I talked to him and I
went on the page from you know there
were still tickets available I mean
there was still third row tickets at the
Garden really
it was six hundred dollars [__] that
[__] it was 600 plus a plane ticket plus
a plane ticket a hotel maybe for two
nights and and you're missing the
meeting
money right there [__] you know no
guys it's [__] it it's LA and donuts man
yeah no no no no listen I feel bad we're
just Another Brick in the Wall anyway
I'm not the type of guy that will
that could look at my wife and go you
know what man and it's on a personal
level it's not like what you would be
happy and unhappy with right if I went
home I could sell my wife anything
my wife was like every other wife in the
world she just wants to be happy she
should pull up the [__] Terry Doom
[__] for a few but then she understands
you know my wife is Terry Doom you know
she'll find the worst thing and bring it
up yeah damn it some Chinese woman I
said I know you're gonna you go to the
comedy stuff she goes no you should go
to the Communist there's a lot of Asian
come here's a couple Chinese people
because my wife is like yeah it's a
16-hour flight who the [__] was talking
about the flying the joke gives a [__]
about flying to China I told her just to
go to the [__] thing last night we're
eating dinner she starts with the 70s
about CNN there's people there were 20
at the table she's talking about CNN the
20s I'm like what the [__] are you
talking about nobody's even talking
about the 20s the kids got the earphones
on Felicia's looking the other way you
know what I'm saying what the [__] he
thought I couldn't say that to him
because she'll kill me
but you know after that persistent [__]
I could tell my wife my wife's Dynamite
she ain't gonna [__] be mad at me I'm
with my friends you know but I can't
justify it in my world like to come home
and go I'm taking this money out of the
house account no because I want to go
[__] see David Gilmore you know what
take a 20 go buy the [__] album right
right come back you listen to the album
playing backwards will light it on fire
put the Wizard of Oz on yeah let's get a
[__] wild but you want to take a flight
back lose time see nobody you know you
hate flying that's one extra flight you
want to [__] do it so it's a good
thing then yeah it was a good thing I
feel bad for my brother James
I feel bad because today when I talked
to him he was
you know he's gonna go by himself it's
tonight and tomorrow night Saturday he
was at Radio City Musical which that was
the night to go right that was the night
to see that [__] radio wrestling
so
don't feel bad the other guy from Floyd
couldn't even make it you know what man
I [__] saw him when they were Pink
Floyd
you know I have a couple things I'm very
proud of and that's one of them yeah I
could always that always wins every
argument Roger Waters wasn't there yeah
don't feel bad you know when people talk
about concerts you just gotta drop Pink
Floyd The Wall first [__] night
that's it I trumped your whole [__]
show though cause they got a flying pig
and stuff what do they got
what do they got there on the stage was
that nice well the for the wall there's
a bunch of like theatrics and stuff
right
it was brilliant yeah it really was
brilliant but it's on YouTube I should
probably just check it out what was
brilliant about it is that
if you know anything about the wall it's
four outside it's two albums right four
sides yeah and they went up there
opened up like you know like nothing
they basically went up there
and played like nothing was going on now
you're gonna hit an acid this is why I
forgot this is what the TV when people
go home at home watching the movie The
Wall ask me how many times I've seen the
movie The Wall how many times ever
not even once not even once never
the reason why there's no reason to
is basically because
everybody missed something
you know listen you were not going to go
see Pink Floyd without a hit acid like
Lisa added you come to see David Gilmore
with me
you were doing a hit ass that may be
even too that's the rules they gotta hit
right on right on the ticket I assume
you lick the ticket
we don't even play around
there's no I wouldn't let you go I
wouldn't waste that ticket on you they
leave you out in the park and ask you
before we get in the car David
we're taking liquid ass yeah I gotta go
to work tomorrow to stay home bro it's
better if you just put it in a brownie
and give it to me no no no no no I got
to tell you up front because I don't
want nobody to freak out you know
somebody like this comes we're taking a
hit of acid we're just going don't waste
my time I can't hear a story it's too
old it would [__] break my heart if
you told me some [__] story this is
pink [__] Floyd this is the only way
to do it
Okay so
it had all this [__] right
it had four
four [__] sides okay
this is the beauty about Pink Floyd
the wall that way nobody will ever
understand that didn't go see it
four guys come out they're playing
okay you're on acid
you're on acid you've been smoking dope
all day you're on THC Christmas okay
here we go here's Gilmore right off the
bat now how old are we 15. is Gilmore
right off the bat 16.
he introduces himself right off the bat
behind them there's a screen
okay and it's just throwing
right now they're just playing they're
just throwing
[__] uh hip-hop not him I'm sorry
it's strong enough it's showing uh it's
a deep song what do you call that [__]
uh you know those hippie things those
tie-dye yeah now
you're an acid
ntuc Crystal so you start watching this
hippie design and every once in a while
you're like holy [__] that's music let
me go back to the stage and here's Roger
Waters here's David Gilmore his Nick
Mason and you're watching them
you know and in those days they weren't
screens around the auditorium that you
could watch the man but this was the
Brilliance about the wall that right
here
all of a sudden
a bunch of midgets come out dresses
Dwarfs
okay all right okay and these four
Savages are on stage playing this this
is what the movie doesn't show you this
with nothing shows
and all of a sudden they lay down one
block at a time guys
and they're doing all this
right now
and they're not even paying attention to
the midgets but the midgets are over by
the side right on the live show he's on
the live show could have been amazing to
come be people dressed in green doesn't
matter they're not reacting
to these [__] people right they're
just down down down down down down down
down down down
and all this [__] now listen
you hear like shit's going down right
that screen is coming at you with rocks
and [__] like rocks are coming at you
all right like it's just ending like you
don't know what's going on and all of a
sudden
oh good lover and all of a sudden this
is what you hear and they just stop you
know
and you're like what happened and you're
on the acid and they're doing all this
[__] and those midgets ain't stopping
right they're putting and all sudden a
plane comes up from behind you a [__]
blame is right there you hear that
[__] plane he's right there and he's
moving very slowly he's [__] coming
and all of a sudden he's ready to
[__] hit and [__] bam it's you're
just sitting it
and there's a woman on stage rocking
this [__] baby where'd she come from
who the [__] knows I didn't call him up
and ask him the midgets brought him yeah
all this is going on with this woman and
guess what
the midgets haven't stopped
they're building that wall and they're
building that wall and they're building
that wall and they build around them
this is [__] an hour in
they build around them
you know now they're getting on some
ropes and Pink Floyd's not seeing this
they just keep playing they just keep
playing and this is what people at home
will never understand the Brilliance of
that they demolished you people went
home after they did five shows people
went home and said listen man I know
you're clean and sober it's over
because what they're doing is a mind
assault on your [__] they did it
perfect here we go
this is like a [__] come by with a
[__] piano and [__] and there you are
like what the [__] am I watching and
that screen's still going dog
oh my God and they're still building and
they built
to the end until he comes up with
comfortably numb and now they're singing
it from behind the wall the wall was an
idea that they Roger Waters is such a
scumbag and such an egomaniac that he
goes I love playing music I hate playing
for these pieces of [__] I wish I could
build a wall and separate myself from
these pieces of [__] that's the truth
that's the [__] truth so the ultimate
thing was for him to play side four is
basically done behind the wall
and then until comfortably numb when
Gilmore does his guitar solo
and
they show him on top of the wall
and that's can you imagine so they have
a portion of the concert where you
couldn't see them yeah but Sid Barrett
is on the side eating a box of donuts
right said Barrett is gone fish Baron is
gone
sit Barry disappeared while they were
making wish you were here oh yeah in the
60s yeah right right it was
unrecognizable then this okay so you
have seven minutes in this is the
hottest song on the radio at the time
this is all they play from the album
came out November 30th we went to see
him February 15th the 16th this is all
you heard it's a brilliant song it's
just brilliant
and it sounded just like that thought
do yourself a favor let's end the
[__] parody press in YouTube
February
17th 1980 Nassau Coliseum Pink Floyd why
are we putting ourselves through this
[__] Menagerie well that was a good
description though I gotta tell you but
but yeah let's check it it's brilliant
yeah yeah yeah and and here's what
baffles me about this it's on
you too you're a show I'm sure you were
at I've always asked Steve avillo Hi
friend who I went with who taped it up
because you guys didn't bring your
iPhones that night there was no iPhones
in 1980.
that was [__] nothing but there were
stores that you went to that they made
the [__] uh
they they specialize in the underground
that's so crazy who the [__] do you guys
think you like who the [__] do you guys
think you're dealing with do you guys
think I'm some [__] amateur here no
no
[Applause]
look at that
who's in Jersey right hey suck a dick
that's I think they just recently
knocked it down I stayed though I did a
club there one time maybe two years ago
and I stayed the hotel
Victoria skip forward a little bit
what's that should I skip forward a
little bit sure sure but just
see
[Music]
so they do this album Four albums front
to back in order
to the T
[Applause]
this is the show you were at not the
show but one of these they taped all of
them
[Applause]
[Music]
I want to see these little construction
workers
[Music]
see right now they probably won't say a
show
because this is the beauty of Pink Floyd
they had the camera on Waters right the
cam the the lights on Waters the drummer
and Jurgen player but the midgets were
starting on the sides right
it's crazy how they got a job in show
business but now they have to do manual
labor
I was thinking about that that must
become a shitty job I mean fill up that
wall every night
unless they make really light
[Music]
he was to the T these guys were to the
[__] tea ladies and gentlemen that's
what was so amazing about them no that
sounds like the record
every other watch
the visual is so bad you're not even
gonna see anything at this point this
thing is 30 years old it's the airplane
yeah
[Applause]
this is just too much but you don't see
nothing like this the quality
a friend of mine that I went to a
concert with because like 80 of us went
from my high school really I just went
with four other guys he sent me this one
other one they have 27th
and
uh 1973 that's it
you gotta look deep on that I do want to
show you guys something pretty [__]
intense
just so you guys might learn some what
do you look around looking at the stars
over there put on whipping post by Frank
Zappa watch this
you know I went to Frank Zappa's house
one time did you really was he alive no
he was he was dead but uh a friend of
mine was dating his daughter
it was a weird house all kinds of like
weird dolls and decorations this guy is
a [__] nut looking top one
and I mean this [__] guy could play a
goddamn [__] guitar I mean they'd do
it too they do [__] I don't like they
act like [__] jerk offs right but
besides that I'm talking about Zappa
playing the [__] leads on the guitar
pretty badass man
see I hate all this [__]
[Music]
look at me
[__] around good time buddy
I didn't deserve it was that good a
guitar yeah man
[Music]
put this on playing now one person
reacting to it like Frank Zappa is like
a dinosaur
in today's
yeah a lot of people don't know about
him and he would do perfect today like
if he came back if he was alive today
and he played at Echo Park right in one
week this is Echo yeah this is the type
of [__] they're doing but this sound
louder here watch this guitar playing
food
[Music]
nothing seem to change
this is all Zappa playing the lead on
here he's got like 19 [__] on
state listen
[Music]
he has that bad skills man he could show
up to Echo Park looking just like that
thank you
see all that type of [__] right crazy I
want to shoot a [__] but this is
real right here
[Music]
I'm trying to zapper takes it to another
[__] level I had no idea man yeah man
listen he didn't last as long as he did
because he was a dud his music was not
what most people considered what they
liked he had a weird thing it was off
the wall and it was like the garage is
Off the Wall all that [__] but this is
real
[Music]
people act that way because they got
chops not because they don't have jobs
right it's like when a painter is really
good at painting and he's like well I
gotta do some weird [__] because I'm
bored with this regular [__]
[Music]
I love to see this
I hate covers
I like interpretations
right that's how weird for you no that
makes perfect I know a cover I know an
interpretation this is an interpretation
because of his guitar playing he he
interpreted into his own yeah it's a big
big difference between interpretation
and a cover people always send me covers
and things they drive me [__] right
they drive me [__] crazy right you
know uh you know who does good coverage
that dude from the Black Label Society
stuff and he redoes it he does a good
job you know who does good covers Led
Zeppelin yeah they do they made a career
out I made a career out of [__] doing
Cubs but they've been smart lately
they've been putting the songs they did
right yeah have you seen that on video
with Jimmy Page he just put cashmere up
uh-huh he told how he got the Rifts to
cashmere well he released on the movie
with Jack Black when they did that movie
uh heavy Patton or play it Loud Play it
okay in that movie he does a segment on
how they came up with cashmere and it's
[__] brilliant he just right now he's
got stay with him now he said what
happened yeah yeah yeah he breaks down
stay with a hammer on YouTube to say how
he came up with it how you know people
could say we robbed it what studio
musicians don't speed on music right
that was my [__] idea he did all that
little yeah so don't get me wrong I
[__] love Led Zeppelin I Love Led
Zeppelin I don't care
that's how much I love I love them to
death
and there's people that boycott them
there's people that send me [__] hate
mail they're only hurting themselves
you know why I Love Led Zeppelin
because there's one simple reason why
the live
the live [__] album and the live
footage the live footage when you see
what Jimmy Page and him do but what you
have to really accompany to is you have
to get the night
in 76 when Robin planted the king
biscuit flower hour you could find that
online
you could find that online all right
listen to that interview and then watch
that movie and listen to what Robert
Plant saying you talking about Song
Remains the Same that movie
you know and there's a bunch of
different cuts right like but there's
the sketch cut but that's the one I saw
I also heard that Led Zeppelin
remastered it and when you watch it now
you can see that it's completely off
like yeah the music is still there the
the voice is still there what's mentally
you know over there Sweating Bullets
thinking how can I have another donut
then have another donut you never eat
your skin Them Bones please
yeah it made me very happy it makes me
always makes me happy to get a phone
call from you
you know [__] Tickle Pink man you
know I don't [__] around though I know
you're not a real [__] mohegans
and uh I got Lee here so when I know you
were coming back we said [__] it Joey
doesn't [__] around he says when you
gonna be back I love you see you later
that's how he does it no drama yeah
exactly I love it I love it that's why I
don't want to [__] [__] around with
this [__] but anyway you know like all
great podcasts even though you're having
a good time they all come doing it it's
true
see if these steroids are gonna let me
[__] sleep now
told these things they're not going to
let me sleep that's why are these are
these donut steroids no no the steroids
because I feel like I'm growing already
no no no no but anyway listen guys let
me tell you something you know we're
always trying to push food on you
because we're a bunch of fat [__]
sometimes if you push healthy stuff on
you and it's uh you know I I like Blue
Apron I'm a Believer in Blue Apron it's
it's the calories are low but there's
something else I'm gonna believe I'm a
Believer in uh for you people don't know
what the Church of What's Happening Now
is brought to you by naturebox.com
dedicated to making smart delicious
snacking easy you deserve better than
high fructose corn syrup and red eye
number 578 nature box snacks taste
delicious without any high fructose corn
syrup that's the [__] that kills you
trans fat MSG artificial colors
sweeteners or flavors none of that crap
NatureBox makes finding a range of
options from healthy to indulgent to
easy they combine unique flavors with
ingredients you can pronounce to create
great snacks you may not want to share
trust me they're delicious the Sriracha
cashew is delicious the chocolate Nom
Nom is delicious the South uh American
plantains delicious they've got 100
seriously delicious options to choose
from all delivered here's the secret to
your door the same way Damon showed up
with those donuts and changed our world
tonight is the same way nature boxes
show up all right and you'll never get
board with the NatureBox snacks because
every single month they release new
snacks to choose from like the the my
favorite is the the salt and pepper
lentils I I think that is my favorite
snack in the world Mercy there's a nice
spicy food and she even eats it all
right so do me a favor say goodbye to
weird mystery ingredients and start
snacking confidently with NatureBox
visit naturebox.com Joey to get 50 off
your first box now okay again head then
naturebox.com Joey right now and give 50
off the right snacks for 2016. that's
fifty percent off your first box of
delicious high quality snacks sent
directly to your door so do me a favor
again go to naturebox.com scroll down
the page look for snacks go look through
the cashews go look through the Nom Noms
I mean it's gonna be a tough decision
but you gotta break five of them knock
yourself out you know why because we're
gonna give you 50 off your first box so
again go to naturebox.com to get 50 off
your first box all right and that's it
it's that easy number two we've been
talking about this early I mean Lee
broke it down for you a little bit night
after night two people laying the same
bed but when it comes to time to buy a
new mattress only one gets their way
until now we're introducing the Helix
sleep where you can buy mattress online
customized for both you and her okay for
all him whatever for hundreds of dollars
instead of thousands okay go to
helixsleep.com and answer a few simple
questions based on four key preferences
and the result will be a custom sleep
profile used to build you the most
comfortable mattress you'll ever sleep
on okay and I guarantee your significant
other would be happy too whether it's
she or he your mattress will arrive at
your door in about a week and shipping
is 150 percent free so right off the bat
we're sending you we're saving you money
and for couples helix customizes each
side of the mattress personalized to
suit each of your bodies the way you
both sleep so the Helix customers report
a 30 Improvement in overall Sleep
Quality you have a hundred nights to try
it out and if you don't love it they'll
pick it up for free and give you 100
free refund okay no questions asked
that's why everyone from GQ Magazine to
Forbes they're all talking about the
Helix sleep so do me a favor go to
helixsleep.com Joey and get 50 beans
that's 50 off your order that's
helixsleep.com Joey and get fifty
dollars off your first order start
sleeping like uh like a prison invict
and get you to take care of yourself you
go online you take the survey you order
the mattress knock yourself out I mean
they got great stuff in this pamphlet
you know I would be with you for two
days reading all the good stuff but just
do me a favor go to helixsleep.com right
now take a look at all your options take
the test and then put Joey and get fifty
dollars off your first daughter I want
to thank Helix sleep I want to thank
NatureBox and I want to thank my people
on it with the Hem Force protein and the
Mike Dolce protein that my main man lee
science enjoying so much look at the
face
did you see that he's ready to go see
Pink Floyd he is he's ready to [__]
do something Lisa yeah on that Helix
mattress you're [__] up [__] up dude
you're [__] up I love it Lee when you
get [__] up all right
when the camera's off oh good you get
another [__] donut and knock yourself
out who takes care of you boy your Uncle
Joey and for you [__] that
don't know let me let you up what's
cracking up next [__] week Buffalo
New York all right next Thursday Friday
Saturday the 21st to the 23rd and the
following week I'll make crackers in
Indianapolis that's right [__] one of
my favorite [__] joints in the
country next week I'll be in buffalo
eating [__] beef on Wick like a
[__] you understand me
[__] the Weight Watcher points [__] the
donuts I mean turn it up and Buffy what
happens in Buffalo
I'm in Spokane with Segura okay who the
[__] goes to Spokane me and Tommy he's
going like a bowling yeah yeah yeah
[__] I love you guys with all my heart
thank you for always giving us the
opportunity to entertain you on a
[__] Monday night what's up dog and
for people the video is going to be on
his video it's going to be on Vimeo no
more YouTube because I'll take this down
so we're going to stream on we play
videos but we're gonna shoot the video
Vimeo and put them up right it's Joey
Coco Diaz on Vimeo all right okay I love
you guys thank you very much for
watching see you Wednesday night I'm
gonna blow your mind with the guest on
Wednesday night so stay black what do
you want to close with Buddy uh what are
we gonna close with
let's close with uh UFO uh
uh lights out
[Music]
thank you
if you keep telling me
[Music]
foreign
laughs
[Music]
tomorrow
thank you
[Music]
foreign
come on
thank you
[Music]